en pandemia emergencia climática y
nuevas relaciones en la conferencia de
seguridad de múnich celebra una edición
especial en formato virtual servirá
especialmente para replantear la
relación transatlántica entre europa y
eeuu tras la era de donald trump en el
gobierno
este será el primer compromiso
multilateral con europa del presidente
joe biden el presidente al ahora sobre
la importancia de nuestros lazos
transatlánticos y la necesidad de que
estados unidos y europa aborden retos
globales juntos
reuters la nueva relación transatlántica
tiene como retos un liderazgo común
frente al auge de china también servirá
para establecer unidad en la relación
con rusia e incluso el jueves se supo
que la colaboración empieza a
fructificar eeuu está dispuesto a
reiniciar conversaciones con irán bajo
invitación de la unión europea creó en
la conferencia participarán también el
presidente de francia emmanuel macrón la
canciller alemana angela merkel y la
presidenta de la comisión europea ursula
von der leyen que tras la posesión de by
dent
celebrado el regreso de eeuu al
multilateralismo europa esta lista para
un nuevo comienzo con nuestro socio más
antiguo y fiable por eso la comisión
adoptó recientemente una nueva agenda
transatlántica con visión de futuro
william el origen de la conferencia de
múnich se remonta a 1963 cuando alemania
estados unidos y los países de la otan
se comenzaron a reunir anualmente para
contrarrestar la fuerza de la unión
soviética